Chris is with us Chris is in Columbus
Ohio hi Chris welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hello Dave thanks for taking my
call
sure what's up well I just finished the
Total Money Makeover book about a week
ago and I'm really getting on track to
try to get rid of the only debt I have
in my life right now is the car that I
can sell and I'm working extra hours and
basically I reached a point where I was
sick and tired and I want to be a
millionaire I want to retire a
millionaire and all the people around me
at work and some people at church and
whatever are saying that not only is it
kind of like an immoral goal like this
idea that having a million dollars is
kind of like evil and not a good
spiritual play but also a lot of people
saying that well with more money comes
more problems and more headaches and I
guess since you're the only millionaire
that I know I wanted to ask you directly
does there's more money actually make
more stress and problems because the
more I'm at I'm saying it would be great
to not worry about money again yeah well
money makes you the more money you get
it makes you more of what you already
are if you're depressed and you get
money you will become deeply depressed
if your family is dysfunctional and you
get money they get crazier than a bean
if you are an angry person you get money
then you become a tyrant if you are a
kind person that loves God and believes
that you're managing the money for God
that you're what we Christians call a
steward then you become a very generous
person and a person who's very concerned
about their family legacy all of those
things are biblical and if your church
is teaching you that the only way to be
spiritual is to be poor your church is
teaching heresy right that money is evil
there is nowhere in scripture that says
money is evil
it doesn't say money is good it says the
love of money is the root of all evil
right and when you say that and that
material things take on a spiritual
component and money being a material
thing that is a form of heresy known as
Gnosticism and well rich people can't
get into heaven oh really
but murderers and prostitutes and drug
dealers can if they accept Jesus but
rich people can't see now you're now
you're discounting the power of the
cross and that's called heresy and so
this is a very shallow backward toxic
form of Christianity that's not even
real Christianity and and but it comes
from the type of people that are in that
particular congregation or denomination
that causes that and that's not a
prosperity gospel it's just reading the
Word of God and understanding what it
says so so no you're not unspiritual now
if you think you own money or you get
uppity because as we say in the country
just because you've gotten some money
now that's unspiritual and there's all
kinds of warnings in scriptural
scripture about the dangers of wealth
but the trick spiritually is to say I
don't tend to believe and act on the
fact that I don't own the money I am
managing it for God and God tells us to
do three primary things with money when
he gives it to us to manage the first
thing is we take care of our own
household or worse than an unbeliever
have you ever heard that one yes sir the
second thing is we change our family
tree and proverbs says a good man leaves
an inheritance to his children's
children it doesn't say it's evil to
have an inheritance it says a good man
not an evil man a good man leaves an
inheritance to his children's children
David did not build the temple Solomon
built the temple you know whose money
Solomon used David's it was inherited
money so David is evil a man after God's
own heart that's absolutely ludicrous
and horrible doctrine not not reading
the Word of God I mean it's just
let the world teach you theology it's a
bad idea
and so but as far as problems you're
always gonna have problems
I got problems my car breaks down but it
doesn't break down as much as when I was
driving a junky one and when it does
break down I pick up phone call somebody
to fix it I used to lean under the hood
with a wrench
I don't have to bust my knuckles doing
that anymore because I got some money to
pay a guy to do that so it doesn't solve
all my problems but it sure doesn't you
know if I get a headache I can afford
the Tylenol you know that's the
difference so you know it doesn't make
everything perfect it makes you more of
what you are and it's not unspiritual I
cover this in the book the legacy
journey I'll send you a copy is my gift